The look on your face right now...
is priceless.
[LAUGH] whispers wow.
What's up, guys. Welcome back to the lab.
Today, we're trying another one of those experiments you really shouldn't try at home, and that's why we are in iJustine's home.
Hello. I've also got this, just in case.
That's right. Today, we're gonna be playing with fire.
So safety precautions are in place and the only things we're going to be using for this experiment are a large metal bowl of water,
we're using some dish soap and some butane that I just went down to the Home Depot and got about 3 and an half dollars.
So, when you guys add water and dish soap together, and you take a straw and you blow in it, bubbles form.
What are we doing?
So guys, update what we just did is we took some dish soap
And we put into the water stirred it around and used one of these yellow straws
I'm not sure if they're color specific, but we did use yellow to blow some bubbles and bubbles
We've got a lot of bubbles, so pretty elementary. Everybody knows that dish Soap forms bubbles, right?
But what if we happen to trap a different kind of gas inside those bubbles?
What if instead of using air, we try to fill it up with something like a butane instead? I have absolutely no idea
we're going to find out so we're gonna have just seen here go ahead and remove the cap and
[we're] gonna find on this butane bottle is there's a little nozzle sticking up here at the top that's actually for refilling like barbecue igniters
And lighters and go to that nature there
Sometimes refillable these ones probably [are] I think yeah that's definitely not one
Yeah, yeah, these are made to purchase multiple
But the interesting thing about this if you press this down
You get a little squirt of gas that flies out there, and if you were to light that gas on fire. [oh]
Holy crap!
sweet
My dog is extremely excited about it improvised [flamethrower]
[and] this is one of those things you don't try at home right leave it to us expert, so definitely a flammable gas
Thank you [very] much
So go ahead and take your canister [of] Butane all right?
We're going to flip this upside down
And we're gonna stick it straight down to the bubbles until it hits the bottom of the bowl yeah when you feel they contact keep
Pushing okay, it's going to start forming bubbles until that entire container is completely full okay. Do you know what's going to happen? Yes, okay?
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
That's good stuff. [hot] now if you angle, Er to the side a little bit
You can get a lot [more]
So a moment of truth now what I need you to do is I need to put your hand in the side
I want you to get a little bit soapy
So when you pick up the bubble of the bubble stain your hand dry skin and bubbles don't mix very well
So you wanna get your hand nice [and] soapy and wet so [come] [in] from the bottom switch your hand around a little bit
And then when you feel, it's nice and sticky you go ahead and scoop up [some] of those bubbles there
And I see how all the bubbles are popping here. That's because some of the skin is still dry
So what really works best if you put your hand down the bottom okay?
[push] it around your whole hand covered in that nice soapy water
Let's go ahead and move this dish out of the way, far out of the way, and now this is the important part
I'm going to take some paper towel and just brush off the bottom of your hand
So that we only have the bubbles on the top
All right now. This is actually quite a bit
This is an enormous amount to do for your first time
Are you comfortable doing this no, but let's do it, okay?
so when we're going to light this off [justine] is going to open her hand fully and
What I want you to do is count from three to one if they claim on okay three two one flame on
Did you see that?
That was amazing you didn't even flinch
She's just like it burns, and then she just as they're holding this ball of fire
What am I supposed to do with it that [was] impressive wow? [so] what did you feel tell us about that experience?
[oh] warm
I think I was
over
Exaggerating a little bit because I think the shock [of] seeing my hand on fire was more scary than the feeling because it was like
A slightly can you put your hand at the top of the toaster? It's like that warm Mm-hmm?
Like if you like a run over top of a candle for a second you can feel it warming up
Then I quickly dissipated that was cool
That was like three or four seconds her hand was on fire
And she just held it like I think you're a natural that was really cool. We'll try this again
Okay, okay one word of advice guys the small bubbles hurt
so if you have a lot of small bubbles wipe them off and get some bigger bubbles they burn a lot quicker the
Small bubbles have a tendency to linger. So we're just going to clean this up
We're going to soak your hand in there again
Swish it around wow this is neat neat it is pretty neat. You heard it here [first]. It's neat
This looks really cool. Go ahead [and] scoop those up
And I love the way that it kind of like sticks to the bottom of your hand as you're pulling it out now obviously
flames rise
So if you have bubbles on the bottom of your hand it will burn and that's why it's very important to pull all these bubbles
off
You shouldn't try this at home. [it's] really what we're saying that's looking pretty good. All right. I'm going to like this
I'm [just] going to bring it [right] down for you ready, and then I just like to exact what [any] last time?
I just seen the human torch
He didn't know that was coming
Totally surprise, and I expect it wasn't it. How are you doing? How's your hand?
She's wanting to say it like it hurts. It really doesn't but it's honestly just like look at this look at this the perfect manicure
It looks beautiful. This is a small hint of charred human hair yeah, that's cool. [no], we feel actually your hands to look great
That's good. That's beautiful
Wowie [like] that would be burning you
Beautiful bubbles of mad science, are you ready to burn can we just go?
Okay, the old library
That's beautiful. Isn't it it's beautiful. Okay?
now
you want to see something really crazy the reason that I told you to move this out [of] the way the first time is because
You accidentally drop a flame in there the whole things can go up. It's absolutely insane so we're gonna try that next on purpose I
Do a few little bubbles in your hand when it lights on fire
I just want you to come down and touch the bowl and back up okay, okay? Wow all right. Let's see what happens
It can't be like the bowl the [human] [torch] ignition prepare yourself because this is about to be a wild ride
[it's] the best time ever
Guys right now justine is literally becoming a firebender. She's gonna throw fire from her hand into this bowl here
Let's do it three
two one oh
Oh jeez, Oh my...
Rise. Is that not amazing ?
I'm sure you guys are surprised that this hasn't happened Sooner in my kitchen
Then absolutely amazing that she took fire from her hands and lit that whole bowl on fire. I'm speechless
This is so awesome
So obviously guys
playing with fire
Should only be done under adult supervision if ever but we did this demonstration for you to see what could happen if you accidentally?
Like let the flames travel into the bowl big ball of fire super dangerous very dangerous
Please don't try it at home and adult supervision if I'm supervising you do not try it
How's your heart feeling good? I think [that's] more in shock than anything. I'm more interactive
It didn't hurt [but] I thought that it hurt it basically like tricked my mind and thinking that I was too in pain
But I really wasn't because I saw myself on fire so like as you were watching your hand burn
You were like subconsciously thinking this really hurts a lot
Yeah, that's why I'm screaming out like this really hurt. You just felt like it should've.
whoa
That was actually pretty cool, did you see that?
I guess it didn't burn by skin or my body, it's probably not going to burn this yeah, it actually burns up pretty quickly
It's all about the dissipation of heat what you have to keep in [mind]
Is that flames travel upward? And that's why if you have any bubbles hanging around on the bottom of your hand?
It's going to burn the bottom of your hand and if you have bubbles on your wrist
It's going to burn off your hair, and it's gonna make the whole place smell like burning human hair. Right,  burning flesh.
But hey if you're not getting hurt, you're not having fun, right?
wait
You know they say go big or go home? Well? I'm already home, so
That is a lot. Oh my goodness. Are you ready to take this on? Yes! That is huge okay? Ah?
That was good, perfect, insane you nailed it. Whoo. Yeah
She did it guys. This girl is insane. It's like a shock every time you do it
It's just like what is happening like my body is on fire
Yeah, well you're literally shooting fireballs out of your freaking palms of your hand
That's about as human torch as you
can get yeah, that's cool. So we still got some butane bubbles left in here
That should be light you on fire we mmM, okay?
Ahh god, that just scares me so bad
was that cool?
That was so scary
Here you smell the burning hair on my hand? You're burning. So yeah
It's not without risk guys you might end up with some scorched human hair, but that's no big deal it's part of
I mean some people wax some people burn
This is the iJustine fire slap in three, two, one.
Oh god so scary.
Yeah
That's amazing, but you do it like a pro every time!
It's just so scary
It's amazing how it goes up so quickly. (mouth sound effect) Pretty cool huh?
The look on your face right now is priceless
[laughs]
That is awesome
But very cool experiment guys now
you know how to take butane and some dish soap and water and makes the human flaming torch effect
Big thanks for iJustine for joining us for this experiment, for putting her safety on the line
She actually had no idea what to expect
No, he didn't he was like hey, so how about I'd like you on fire, and I was a little skeptical
But this actually worked out pretty well. Yes, it was so much fun
You already know who she is, but I put a link down in the description so you can go check out her channel
She's got all kinds of cool videos coming up including one that we're about to go do in the backyard right now
Melting an iphone in a 2,000 degree foundry, so make sure you go check that out
Thanks for joining us for this experiment we'll be looking for you in the next one, talk to you then. Bye
I'm gonna go back to the nail salon they're like why are your finger nails burned off?
What's all this char under your cuticles? Well..
Aww I was going for it. I missed..
[Music]